Here's another way of estimating Pi. Take a one inch needle, and repeatedly
drop it on a sheet of ruled paper whose lines are two inches apart. Call it a
hit if the needle is hitting one of the lines. If you do this a whole bunch of
times, Pi will be approximately equal to the number of drops over the number of
hits. If you're curious about the details, you can check out a Wikipedia page
on this. Clearly, dropping a needle on the floor, and measuring whether it
touches a line thousands of times is not a job that anybody wants to do.
Thankfully, we can make our computer simulate the experiment for us. We
randomly generate a yLow, or the lowest point of the needle, which should be
somewhere between zero and two. Then we calculate an angle a between zero and
180 and use this angle to figure out y high. If y high is more than two we have
a hit. Now do this many thousands of times and you'll have an estimate for pi.
So again you want to randomly generate y low, randomly generate and angle a And
then calculate y high. Which will be y low plus the sine of the angle. And be
careful, because math.sine takes radiance, not degrees. Math.toradians can help
you with the conversion. You can always review the math facts sheet if you
don't quite remember how this works. Here's the start of the program to do
this. And when you put in the number of tries, I recommend using a large
number. At least 30,000. When you write this code, make sure to use the
variable tries to control how many times you drop the needle.